era un viaje de vuelta a casa desde
turquía macedonia del norte pero terminó
en tragedia un autobús que transportaba
turistas se estrelló e incendió en una
autopista a unos 30 kilómetros de sofía
capital de bulgaria dejando decenas de
muertos muchos de los familiares todavía
no tienen información de lo sucedido
puesto un broche de información a las 6
de la mañana lo vi en internet y como mi
primo estaba en turquía me puse a buscar
más información en internet llamé al
teléfono de ves atrás durante 3 o 4
horas pero ni contestan al teléfono ni
tenemos información que fue informados y
aduriz nitties what mi esposo y la
esposa de mi hermano estaban en el
autobús hace 3 días salieron de tetovo
ahora esperamos malas noticias de los
pasajeros sólo siete consiguieron
escapar del vehículo y fueron
trasladados con quemaduras y heridas
leves a un hospital de sofía donde
permanecen estables tras los hechos el
primer ministro macedonio francés se
trasladó a sofía para expresar sus
condolencias junto a su homólogo búlgaro
sacan
quiero compartir mi sincero pésame y el
del pueblo macedonio con el pueblo
búlgaro por la pérdida y que también
aceptamos el pésame del pueblo búlgaro
hacia nosotros lugar ciudad con más las
autoridades todavía no han identificado
la causa exacta del accidente pero la
principal conjetura es que el transporte
chocó contra una barandilla aunque
ignoran si se incendió antes o después
del impacto este accidente de autobús es
el más mortífero de la historia de
bulgaria